hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast crisper seek and guide seek
for design and evaluation of guide RNAs
in CRISPR Castine genome editing systems
presented by Julie zoo professor and
director of bioinformatics Corps
University of Massachusetts Medical
School I'm Alexis Carlos of lab groups
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and produce
serve educational virtual events and
webinars before you begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Xue
I will now turn the presentation over to
her thanks for McCown introduction and
the invitation Alex and it's a great
pleasure to be able to have an
opportunity to speak to you about to buy
conducted packages Christmas Eve and
agonistic I developed to facilitate a
design and an evaluation of Chris Burke
has nine genome editing system before I
get into the details of the software I
would like to give you overview of the
bioconductor genome editing technologies
CRISPR casts nine system and guys ticket
technologies some of you might be very
familiar on some of the technologies so
please bear with me why I gave
introduction to these technologies by
conducting prior tools for analysis and
the realization and
imitation of biologic data initially a
focus on DNA micro data analysis and
visualization and annotation and it
started as the 2001 when my grade
technology took off as the project
matures scope has expanded to and
include all types of genomic data such
as gypsy music and single-cell
sequencing as Emporium acts and kernel
release includes more than 1,500
software packages and more than 1,000
location and experiment data packages is
open source and open development and the
advantage of developing our software in
us by conductor package is that we can
leverage the reach annotation that it
has such as a genome sequence and the
gene and mapping and also we can
leverage the plotting and the
realization and also analysis tools all
ready and available in the by conductor
here are the thousand packages we have
developed here and ranging from
annotation realization and and also a
achieve alignment machine learning
algorithms and attack cqc as a quality
assessment - and genome and editing
software tools the first back in our
packaging we develop is ecology became
known I know she prepare a know is for
integrated analysis of chip-seq data and
you tuner a time limit I'm not gonna
have time to go through all the packages
and if you have any questions please
feel free to email me and today I'm
gonna focus on trooper by Kanaka
packages quiz Pacific and agonistic for
a crisper cast line and general editing
system the discovery are for crisper
cache line system has ignited the
imagination are for researchers and also
clinical scientists
and it feels like and the normal
applications have been developed with
her for almost every day and ranging
from basic biology to genome research
genome channel the gene added him also
for medicine in genome editing a
double-stranded break has made as the
primary site is specifically and double
strand break has made by program a
nucleus such as link of India nucleus
and talents and also Chris Berg has nine
system once the double-stranded break is
made and a genome and you know a motive
repair pathway such as an on hormone ask
Angie journey and homology directed
repair ties were mobilized for non
hormones and the joining pathway is a an
error-prone and rerouting in rendering
insertion deletion and alternatively
when there's a doughnut embolism is
provided hormonal to directed repair
pathway and these to precise being a
replacement before the discovery of the
CRISPR cast nine system and the Inca
finger nucleus our talents has been used
extensively and however and Chris
recognizes a much easier and to
constantly faster to construct and it's
quite effective Chris procrastinating on
it in system it borrows a strategy from
away bacteria fights and the invasion
for a virus when a virus in invades the
bacteria for the first time and the
viral part of the virus DNA sequence
called proto spacer is incorporated in
no bacteria crisp array so Chris Bray is
a place to install the past invaders
being a sequence when the virus invades
again the bacteria Christmas system well
recognized and the sequence and thereby
destroy the virus so
a few years ago and several researchers
have found that and the system can be
engineered that not only can cut an
environment stinger you can cut any
congregate sequence ninnies engineer the
form derived from s pyogenes bacteria
there are two components and the first
component is not probable ah and
depicted as a parabola that that's cast
9 which is a nucleus and derived from
the bacteria the second component is the
SGR a or a single kind of array which
has also two components one is the
across the region depicted a speech and
which forms seminal stem-loop structure
our scaffolding and a second part is no
variable region which has 20 based and
nuclei s pyogenes system which can be
altered to in his engineering deform to
target any sides in a tally size also
have two parts one is the variable is 20
base nucleotides base pair with no
variable region often a SGR a and the
other part called a pan which is a
shorter sequence stands for and pour the
spacer or the juice in the motif
which is an GG in s pyogenes than
bacteria on the other hand
however the pam is not I'm recognized by
anodyne array instead it's bound by the
last nine only when both type portion of
the Aztec site we bond then the cosna
will make a cut and once the Christ nine
makes a double strand break and then the
repair pathway will be mobilized to
either to swap the gene or make a
tackler modification by on our homeworks
and the joining pathway or HDR it seems
data to design a system are garnering
for this system is quite easy because
you are only needed to stand for no time
sequence however when you introduce a
nucleus to a system
another consideration is to avoid
cutting elsewhere which we call off
targets well the soul therefore the
design goal is to maximize the on target
acceleration would call efficacy and
minimize also technical image so hard
wasn't a rule to govern is advocacy and
dr. Ruth's lab and in a study and the
rules by essay more than 1,800 guide
erase tiny across a possible target size
a panel to nine genes and they use the
sequence of feature and for like
standard kind sequence to construct a
model to predict how the secret features
of fátima and cutting advocacy here is a
figure to depict only a mononucleotide
how this mononucleotide affect the
efficacy in different positions are long
extended on kind of sequencing including
four nucleotide before the kind of money
and three nucleotide after the parent
sequence and the top bar is favored
not on the corner bar the more effort
more efficient specific more significant
so for example here as an arrow
indicates that and the see at the
position 20 of the guy not only see
strongly disfavored and g is a highly
favored and in addition to this
mononucleotide and there are other
features of such as a tiny nucleotide
and the GC content of factors as well
and later about two years later 2016
assembler and actually ask adam even
more guilin race and targeting more
genes and constructor are a second stair
cholera cell to and found out that and
an additional features such as mounting
temperature and also the position in a
gene and also have additional
protecting power so they actually
construct another rule called reverse m2
and for a particular size so not only
either advocacy is important we needed
to study in a rule for off target and
horizontal F for Mikey and studied about
700 kinda my parents across for 15
target size in a gene and what they did
is they actually and studying the gun
and I'm very inspiring very the guy and
I buy one nucleotide at Hein so
including all possible single mismatches
and trying to compare Medina with anima
smash here is not he the map depicting
the effects of different positions on
the creeps
efficiency as you can see the green
color means and there's no effect means
the cleavage is high and position as you
can see not only position number of the
position and position also a faction of
tactical image for example position one
to five colored in green means there's
no almost no effect but position 13 to
15 as a great effect in addition they
discovered that although preferred Pam
sequences and Gigi and AG also have a
reduce the effects therefore when we
design guideline we want strict the Pam
sequence to be an GG however when we
search for archival we need to consider
and AG as well
in 2016 the rooster created a bigger
data set you study what a mismatch type
in addition to mismatch position and
number effects of tactical image they
discover that and the mismatch type have
greater effect and it's position
dependent for example our GGG as no
indicator as a red arrow there's no
effect for this mismatch type however ie
DG has a great effect in any position or
position basically in terms other
mismatch type they affect the courage in
position dependent manner in addition
they also confirmed that an Ag and has a
reduce effect plus they've discovered
several other alternative times was a
reduced effect therefore when we trying
to design a gun on a we needed to
consider mismatch type for off tag the
cleavage site prediction when you
introduce a nucleus to know genome you
needed to and have a screening method to
identify in the house in a you know
animal cell animals ourselves and there
are many methods one of nur and least
expensive and also very easy method is
restriction enzyme digestion method in
this example the taki site contains a
pierced new one colored in red pushing
aside and which overlaps wizna a
cleavage side of a case nine specify has
arrow a green arrow after PCR
application the tally the locals if
there is no in those produced the psg1
side was the impact after PST one
digestion and the you will produce two
bands in contrast to one band
without the enzyme however if there is a
changes made in the PST one site that
for example here's a insertion then the
PST once I be lost and the recognitions
are been Bobby disrupted addition of
this enzyme PST one were produced one
band just like the control cell
christmukkah standoff she was very
quickly to increase the specificity and
also to expand the tagging aside there
are many variants of
s9 and also different from different
species have been and have been invented
for example in a deeper de pano d see if
you know what simply f1 there is a
nucleus that recognized a tear each
pants instead of Gigi and Gigi Ridge and
also it's the five prime instead of
three prongs as peak as 9 and another
alternatives for example there's Valley
and Earth panel there are paired
configurations any panel is a pair of
the knee case which it requires two knee
case the bond that we are reduced the
off-target effects and the non orange is
decays now is focal one nucleus also
requires paired so all these with all
these considerations in mind or design
guy Christmas sick as I'm adaptive and
also flexible and and was of high and
not only and identificar eyes using the
published on packet and off target and
matrix to prediction and the side but
also he allows the flexibility to adapt
comma date I guess not from different
species and also pair the configurations
and then we allow to
use a different scoring method for newly
published data and also can't restrict
or constrained the data race to impose
different characteristics of Nogami and
it also allows to restrict site
monitoring by animates the site and in
addition it can design guidelines so and
I close related sequences such as your
specific guideline I design all kind of
arrays can targeted both the videos
although most of the most of the
features have been and some of the
features and have been implemented here
some of the software's and Crispus seek
remains to being the most flexible
what's up hi adaptive ones who make it
easy to use and two main functions all
of the functionality have been captured
or have been simplified and into true
you know workflow function why is called
off technical analysis the other is
called pair two sequences of the
analysis workflow is for Guyana high in
search and obstacle analysis annotation
for one our set of input sequences the
second is compared to sequence workflow
for identify kandaharis that is
specifically player one of the to
improve sequence or tackle it both here
I promise this is the only slide you
know has this parameter setting and so
for make it easy to use that before the
setting or for of target analysis is all
set for no default s pyogenes the most
reward
used and the well characterized one and
all you need is for an input file paths
and also be a Latino name and an a
square scoring method also the Dorset
apologize for this slide being stronger
together and however you can find this
method
in the package by type help and question
help and the process of tag analysis an
orange parameter will be explained in
detail in the help page and the reason
who included so many you know almost
like 61 and 60 per Amber's is that the
the ability to easily change this
parameter to fit in our own needs is the
key to be able to and keep up with the
average evolving new technologies the
simple fuller simply father on a
simplest actually the simplest of
workflow increase basic is finding our
ways without us tagging analysis is
basically non providing any genome and
Popeye ad setting chroma to search with
nothing and you will be able to find on
a guide on ice or in different format
and the advantage for using this
workflow is that and you it's very you
know time is short time it takes less
time and also it's a and it's very easy
to find whether you have a guide on your
sequence before you do extensive search
in your genome in this workflow you can
try as I mentioned to you and there are
pair the new cases have been a plot you
deployed for and reduce all the target
effects to find gun range for this pair
the configuration all you need to do is
basically set find a Paragon raise true
and minimal gap because and a maximum
gap there's configuration climb in the
forest you decide that you 0 and 20 as
your you might know that there's another
variant of for Paragon a high
configuration called
decays 9fuc one which requires the
different configuration and as you can
see in the minimal gap is a fourteen max
cap with 17 all you need to do is set
this
as I mentioned you can use a restitution
site to monitor or screen the mutation
size and here's how you find it dinah
race with student size and overlap with
the and cleavage site here is how you do
that by inside him fighter gallery with
an R you can only equals to a minimum I
apparent size you can change and default
system you can set to 6 and also overlap
you know for cast 9 + SP cast 9 is 17 to
18 that's my car side but for other ok
if you are using different and cast 9
system then you need to change it
accordingly so I suggest a mentioned if
you are using you know trying to find a
galilei's for different the CRISPR
system for example CPI for one and it's
a it requires a tear each Pam and a Pam
locations Phi prime and the garner size
also different and the pen size
different so all you need to do is
change this Pam sighs a guy down a size
and a pen and pen location another one
for example on endemic s9 which actually
has a hem size 8 you need to change that
and also guidance is 23 and change the
Pam to the pen preference
as you know and different garner and
promoters for guidance diseases has a
different constraints or preference for
the guy named pattern for example u6
promoter Diana Patton basically if you
sell Gallup and to and to live okay
basically the current plus G means they
start with G it has the highest efficacy
to 4m synthesis in t7 promoter however
you wouldn't and even the guideline
start with GG the census that would be
more efficient therefore you can set you
know Ghana that pattern for other type
of promoters or other type of constraint
for Ghana you can set whatever pattern
you want and using a regular expression
the parameters I talked about also
applies when you add off trial analysis
new addition to guide on research the
additional parameter all you need is to
add imput genome and sequence PSG know
the it will produce I say what goes to
this basically if a input sequence
improve genome it was not only Ferragamo
a filter Galilei they start search on
target and off timing for each guide an
array and the calculated advocacy and
the cleavage to score and also filter
off targets and then fashion a sequence
and a general report your situations
when you already have a list of
galleries and they just won't search for
all targets then you can skip that by
setting the parameter file again we need
to force
by default and crisper seek use the
weight matrix for predicting advocacy
and alpha targeting image using a
published data and a model from the Sun
lab and a new tab
however if you know the date has said
and it's getting bigger or more
experiment have been constructed them
more accurate efficacy weights or
mismatch weights been produced you can
and change it or incorporated into the
system by setting Africa's equate or
mismatch weights it's important to
indicated whether alpha targets are in a
critical region of the genome for
example AXA in a genome gene name so
what do you want to do is basically and
we needed to add another workflow
another function into this work law that
is annotated target and off targets in
order to do that one needed to and you
put the transcripts DB and Organo and
say edited X I could chew now the
manager to deploy CRISPR seek in the by
conduction environment is that
transcript DB an organelle have been and
it's available in the back conductor and
after the twice a year so that we don't
have to and you know download or monitor
or you know update the genome I have
discussed the parameters are subset of
parameters and the workflow function for
and off tagging analysis and here I'm
gonna go through few files and output
from the analysis and the first of you
and a guide on are a files
you know inside overlap files and
parasites are quite and straightforward
and therefore I'm gonna skip do time due
to time limit I'm going to focus on the
band file and off target sites and also
summary file these here's the
view of the UC exit from UCSC genome
browser and you can input your battle
file and each row is one guide array and
the color is in Greek scale and the
darker is higher efficacy and the
sticker portion of the rectangle
indicates the caste nine creature site
and arrow indicates the strength part
you are - here's one of the most
important one of the output file called
a summary of regarding is a summary file
in this file you're able to see in one
guy on a per row and the position going
to be viewed at UCSC genome browser and
also the target efficacy and the top end
of target score and a restitution side
and as you know the top I here is top 10
or target you can change it there's a
parameter there I can change it - if
you're interested in more you can say
top 20 on top of 5 top 100 and the score
so here's a question how you select you
know the best one like and here you know
if you want and really wants you student
enzyme digestion and to monitor the
cribbage you will want their society to
have a site and if you use other method
and for hide you know other method then
you don't need to have this and for this
example I hide the wine in red and this
one has the highest I think almost okay
in the second highest attack the
efficacy and it pop off target and it's
quite low I mean compared to others me
so and I highlighted this one if you
want to have a one with lowest half
target you'll pick this one and you want
to balanced both or three that you want
to use this one
however us let's say you are interesting
a system that you don't care so much
about off target you really want max -
oh you know
advocacy then you can use the last one
however before you make the final
decision you really want to look the
detailed off-target effects by going
soda and Afghanistan output and because
you want to see whether and the top ten
of targets really is just top one Oh
actually is even a distributor the score
and so here you can see that for each of
time sequence there's a notation about
whether seeing external node if it's in
Excel you want to avoid it and whether
you know it's it's a score it's
alignments really show that the
alignment score can show whether they're
you know that's a critical region of the
guide I got guides and the well is ngg
or energy and also here are more
information about the off target that
you really want to go through that
before you've making a final decision
that's my take home message excuse me
and my collaborators Aaron aronia in the
Brasky lab and interesting and study the
hunting the disease in piling activating
Hernandez gene to cure the disease and
however the honey disease gene is it's
essential gene you can option actually
the postal do often of gene and Napoli
so and so what I just want to briefly
say what is you know hunting the disease
and disease is caused by expansion of
caddy repeats and you know handle
disease gene and so information both
earlier is impossible and it's off not
feasible and thereby we need to design
guys that's recognized that is easily oh
and why leave the and healthier alone
here we helped to design a guide on a
and in order to help them to design and
I we actually and create another
workflow kind of
two sequences which is our motivation
and to identify unless that is
specifically targeted one of the two
sequences are both and here I will use
this too
basically we have a to impress
acquaintances and the first to find a
gallon a and for each of the sequence
and then search for off target for the
other sequence and it calculated a plea
to score and compare the sequence and
also compare them the closer related
sequence and they are effects and the
senior was a difference so here is and
sequencing we identified our gonorrhea
we'd identify that and have a great
great discrimination between a chilly oh
and a senior as you can see the top
panel was in the bottom panel at our
panel uses the of targeting and
calamansi score calculator and calculate
that using the advanced lab and remember
dance lab onion model know the position
and the mismatch number effects the
bottom one is a from zoo lab and which
models also the mismatch type for your
specific can I design we need to use the
second one and because otherwise it's a
symmetric and then you will not have a
good description as you can see in the
top the discrimination only seven point
nine nine ten point nine percent the
bottom line show that they can have 46
no percent for it yeah and thereby this
extra she improved of time scar in here
can show that it can come for difference
on your specificity here and I'm going
to talk about it genome-wide unbiased
identification of a double strand break
in Weber by sequencing corrugated seek
and our we develop a cage to analyze
such data so guys it's a published in
nature method 2015 and
you know okay so here is how you know
for design guidance and for Christmas
nines you know anything for star
produces the most important things
minimize the off target and previously
you know just you know select some Gino
site and to test whether there is a
cleavage but it's very important to find
out genome-wide where's not off target
and what's a collegiate rate now several
method have been developed in one of the
most popular needed to conduct method is
called galaxy and briefly and galaxy who
relies on the non Hamas and joining and
repair pathway to Kukui introduced a
double strand oligonucleotide to tag the
crisper cast nine added in our cleavage
aside and I integrated aside into the
cliffside and followed by you know a and
repair adapter ligation and followed by
a hanger specific type of strain
oligonucleotide specific application I
created a a library which is followed by
high super sequencing to and basically
and gosh the and the size and also the
creatures efficiency or afternoon of
target creatures rate in this protocol
is quite easy to conduct experimental II
however and biomechanical analysis is
not straightforward for example there is
mod molecular index could you me and
it's incorporated there to prevent or to
for removing of the PC a PCM on PC a and
bias and also there's index and pista
amplified index involved and to identify
them different examples so we develop
package called Isaac
to analyze such a data set and as you
can see they are usually in this
protocol there are two libraries and
wines we call a strength the price
library and ladder from - library so for
here you can see the or legal tag being
corporate it was system from and it's a
colored in red on the top and the
current mean polluting about them and we
needed to identify the size with this
however you know money the system also
produce some of the sequence of resolve
this so we needed to remove and the
sequences without this tag because this
time you know this tag and this tag
actually indicated where where is not
the cleavage site is there no tag we
need to move it and also we need to
identify where is the exact site and by
here we tagged a here DX our genomic and
integration side about on a black arrow
last second a black arrow and from a
first top one that the first arrow in
the second part and here so here's the
workflow our for our package and the
kind of secret packages on the bottom
and wrapped in the faster you know
rectangle and the table was a
preprocessor a preprocessor as I said
that we needed to identify and in that
we identify different samples by using
the index and we need the map to know
genome and also we need to find and you
me for each sequence so that we can
remove a PCR bias and always and
pre-process scripts are available in our
website and CCD and there's also
available and you know publication in
PMC genomics then after the preprocessor
the map the file and the juma file and
also no data on a file and the reference
you know
I'm used as an input from a guide city
package and I can see briefly the galaxy
package package basing that he has
really process and his move though map
you know no mapping quality reads and
the weather it has a presence of DST a
tag and also remove duplicate rates
using using the Jimmy and also define
where is the integration position and
the tagging the original reads in the
strand and then aggregate reads and use
a window based approach to identify
picks and actually just ran a specific
page please peaks and then merge
neighboring peaks and feel for them and
then we and using identify the peaks and
the final homology to Netaji decide and
the option that we have or you know if
you have a control sample you can
substrate on peaks from control sample
associated the genomic features as
optional and a general report and then
always and also can compare peaks with
difference in the nucleus so here is a
example of we we G a free site and from
our guide actually one guided seeker
data and as you can see and the tag
integration size it actually has all
these reads and piled up there and most
of reads and I'm located an e other are
you naturally the Eclipse IDE which
indicate that it's quite a good tag good
a system to monitor the website and so
here in the forepeak calling we have a
window based approach in DeForest
planning based you can change as easily
because of different size of the guide
our different Pam sequence might have a
different preference of this so you may
change it and also I can see that the
was enhance actually is a downstream of
the cleavage site and the Creek counts
on upstream and after we
created peaks for different strains then
we merge that use this as a biscuit
orientation actually and I forgot to
tell you that actually you not only
configure the peaks using a number for a
reason it's different windows windows
you know these different windows
you also can also have a function that
allows you to use na and background
counts as a to model or Poisson
distribution then finding a p-value for
each window and then you can use P
married who filter as well to make it
easy to use we can basically and in copy
the owner functionalities in through one
workflow function called guide
psychoanalysis there was more than 60
parameters and for the default s peak
has nine which is mostly widely used and
also well characterized and you only
need to tell them what genome you you
assert you want to find out the homology
on a guideline file and alignment in
purifying you mean profile which are
from the pre process and steps so here
after you use the cases you can use this
function for for example you can analyze
now guys to get data from SP case nine
which is a default which is quite an
easy and also you can use either for and
MLK's nine also we discussed and they
have different pam preference and and
also get a size and and also you can
analyze CP every one which is you know
it's a different actually not only
different pam sequence also develop m or
in pain pain position which is by prime
and you can annotate off targets you can
imagine them from multiple experiments
to facilitate comparison among different
nucleus configuration or very
Varun's so here is the output phone
another function called combine off
targets frequently when you are and try
to investigate on
new nucleus or new configuration one
part common practice is to include now
you know commonly use the one and all
study different treatment different you
know different compression and it's easy
to compare them if you use this combined
of targets they can merge enough targets
and then create a create a Venn diagram
for you quickly and examine whether the
newly created a newly designed has nine
system it's a better one or you know
worse wine in terms of tactically for
example here the right side one one
called SP has nine empty and has a much
less of taka now for journalistic
there's an honesty in the pre process
that scripts you can download them and
it basically including you know how to
assign different samples p53 some
indexes being barcode and I'll removed
actors and it's try to unify to read and
mapped Regina the scripts are readily
user and configurable the reference the
help and the both packages have been
published in the paper and following
paper and so and they're not of use
cases are already there and also in the
back and a paycheck packaging we have
and the not only you use pages for each
function but also there and use cases
for different scenarios talking there on
a user guide and also we have given like
workshops and you know Department also
in an impact actor and you feel free to
go through there then to find the
relevant materials now future directions
so I think we need a more precise
Carolina advocacy prediction also more
accurate after kilometer progression and
I think more data set to become
malleable like expanding for example gas
you can become malleable then we come on
incorporating this
into and the cleavage and prediction are
of factly which prediction and then
incorporating in Christmas eek I think I
have something
Oh oh I see for the first line as
cheapness supported by conductor Orton
place the fourth that dotted line and
for any questions please feel free to
post them in the support par conductor
site and the advantage to post there is
the question and answer up you know
archived and searchable and also on
users it can help the other to answer
questions ok now I would like to thank
Alex for hemming here and the teaming
and Tiffany for for hosting list and
also want to thank my collaborators and
UMS and also browse the MIT and geo tag
facts about Co members and thank you
very much for 4/4 time for your time
attention and but it doesn't me know if
you have any questions thank you thank
you dr. Zhu for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask each do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is how do you
calculate rule set to efficacy oh yes
so it's great question usual cell - you
can set the rule that is fat equals okay
question and quote root underscore rural
set to underscore 216 by default is raw
7 1 which is his reward center 1 through
solid 14 and you can get information
by type help unquote actual help and
premise parentheses and then of target
analysis presses again in our and
console thank you
now our next question is how do you
specify the program to use the off
target matrix from root lab which models
done this match type as well so again
there's a and you can use the scoring
that method equals CFG score by default
is as su is answer that and here also
you can use the help again help
parentheses after analysis presses and
you'll see the detailed description of
scoring data method and rule set data
set
thank you now dr. zira our next question
is how do you pick the best guides from
the summary file and off target file
it's a great question and it really
depends on the goal and of your
experiment if it's the first arrow
predict purpose the major on the top
priority is to minimize the off target
so you would want to pick in the
cardinalities that have minimum of
targets and also you want to look in on
the detailed off target I'll put a file
to make sure there are tagged total
after not only the total of time scores
low but also there's no major of target
that's in critical region of the gene
such a or genome such as you know hacks
on now however if you are into are just
do a perform screening examiner to knock
down some gene and that you want to find
a sound you know just just for screen
animals then maybe Africa sees in the
prior primary consideration for you and
for some others you may be one should
think you know have
combined and consideration for example
you want to have a quite high efficacy
you know but not necessary and the
lowest them you know are [ __ ] or you
want have very minimum of targets but
then have some kind of consideration for
also for kyla efficacy because you know
wants them have no effect at all so it's
really kind of quite a complex situation
mm-hmm question it really depends on
what's your go of an experiment thank
you for the great question now can I run
a genome-wide search of the GaN Ari's
excuse me of the RNAs and yes definitely
and actually some people phone I think
if I remember the name actually and from
I think it from Harvard and call the
CRISPR core they try and they actually
trying to use this to design like
genome-wide guides and library so yes
definitely and if you won't do that
depend on the species if we have a big
like large genome sequence file for
example human you won't run it in
cluster and says cluster a framework for
example you may want to split enough
sequence into different files and run
them you know parallel then combine the
results later there's a nice new page
and it and it looks like we have time
for one more question
so what do I do if the species I am
designing G RNAs for does not have I'm
available in the by actor okay that's
it's also quite a question you can and
create an a BST node using and BST
afford which is available in by
conductor as a as a package you
basically forged in the BST no and
engagement you also can use compared to
sequence to do that using the second
sequence and as the second sequence as
the original sequence you have and the
first one we just you know have a
sequence you want to search and that's
the one of the other
approach but then the best one would it
be using a critical analysis a function
workflow function and however you create
your own VST no package is accordion
tuner guidelines and in the bioconductor
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Zia for her presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing there
January of 2019 you will receive an
email from laberd's let me know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that enough with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye